One night
[Silence]
you
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing in
A summary of
authored by
Ramadan.
The question now and the issue that the
author now takes us into is
how does a month
Ramadan specifically any of the 12 lunar
Islamic months generally
how does the month officially
what marks the month's official
commencement.
How do we know that the month begins?
How do we affirm
that the month has begun? And thus it
can become common knowledge as we
mentioned.
So we mentioned before a couple of
principles. In order to understand this
chapter, we have to take these two
principles. Number one, the crescent
itself is not the month. The crescent is
an indicator of the month.
The month is the time in which the
majority of the people and particularly
the people that are in charge of these
things,
the leadership
acknowledge that a month has commenced.
That is when it becomes the month. That
is the month itself. The crescent is an
indicator of the month. That's number
one. Number two, he began the author
began this entire research here on the
narration of
where he says
in which he says
Bkari Muslim
fast
for fast at its sighting meaning in
the crescent and end your fast at its
sighting. And if you are unable to see
if you're if you're if you are
obstructed from seeing the moon then we
fall back on the principle and that is
that
shaan will be 30 days or whatever
month we happen to be in is 30 days.
So the new month does not commence until
clear evidence either by way of a clear
sighting of the crescent or by way of
deduction that it could physically not
be more than 30 days. These are the only
two ways if we take this narration and
this principle that I've mentioned to
you that the crescent itself is not the
month. It is an indication of the month.
We will now understand the rest of what
he mentions. He says,
[Silence]
Who can
suam?
[Silence]
He says the month of Ramadan, again
specifically Ramadan,
the month of Ramadan commences
once it is cited by one trustworthy
person. If one trustworthy person who is
capable
and trustworthy
cites the moon and informs that he cited
the moon,
then this is an indication to go ahead
and affirm the month or that Shaan has
been completed to 30 days. One of the
two. Then he cites an narration
collected by Abu Dhen
on the authority of Omar.
He says the people were looking to see
the moon. They were expecting it. And so
I mentioned to the messenger of Allaham
that I saw the moon. And so he fasted
and he commanded that the month be
fasted that it commence. And we know
that this was at least the third year
after Hij
and
Omar
he was 15 in the third year after hij.
So he was considered a youngster amongst
the rest of the companions.
[Silence]
He says, "And if the crescent of Ramadan
is obstructed,
then
we complete 30 days for Shaaban."
As was mentioned previously in the
narration of Abira,
he says, "And as for the month of Sha
Shaw," so this is the end of Ramadan,
the beginning of the 10th month.
Then the end of Sha is only
affirmed. It's sighting needs two
people to cite it. So to start the
month, it's one person because it's
likely. To end the month, we have to
have two trustworthy people to have
cited, whether they be together or
separately.
[Silence]
Ramadan.
Muslim.
So he then cites a narration on the
authority of Abdman
a much lesserk known companion. We all
know
well he has a brother and his brother
was Muslim as well. His name was Z. And
so his son Abdul Rahman, so we're
speaking about the time of the
he was a governor and he as it was
customary the governance and the
religious authority were one. And so the
governor of any place would be the one
that would give the and lead salah
and so forth. and he
addressed the people and gavebah on
the day in which people were unsure.
Unsure of what? Unsure of the end of
Ramadan and the beginning of Sha. So it
was the 29th either the 29th of Shabb or
the 29th of Ramadan.
And he said, "Indeed, I have sat in the
company of the companions of the
messenger of Allah sallall.aii wasallam
and I asked them about this issue and
they informed me more than one that the
messenger of Allah sallall.aii wasallam
said clearly
fast to the sighting and break your fast
to its sighting." meaning for sha at the
end of Ramadan and slaughter to its
sighting meaning the commencement of
he says and if it is cloudy and the
sighting is obstructed
then if two trustworthy Muslims
inform that they have cited the moon
then fast and also So break your fast.
Meaning affirm by that sighting the
beginning of Ramadan and affirm by that
sighting the end of Ramadan. When we
take this narration and the narration of
Omar together, we come to this
conclusion that the author came to and
that is that the month of Ramadan begins
with the sighting of one and ends with
the sighting of two.
And it could be understood that in the
time of Ibin Omar
that he had received word of the
sighting from someone else other than
Ibar. And so some scholars view that the
sighting of everyone is affirmed by two
not just one. Now obviously
in our times today we're not dealing
with this kind of issue anymore in this
way
and that is that we have communication
at breakneck speed and we have
connectivity to the ends and corners of
the earth. We can speak to people in New
Zealand and Australia. We can speak to
people at the far ends of the Pacific
all the way to the far ends of the
Atlantic. And so because of this, it
becomes much bigger than just one or two
people.
This kind of connectivity
was not around at that time. And so
every group of people in every town,
village, etc.,
They would receive word, they would site
the moon locally, right? And they would
begin to fast
and maybe in major cities the Khalifa or
the governor would send word out and
would send messengers out to the
neighboring villages. But for the most
part, it was likely and it did happen
that people in the far east did not see
the moon and people in the far west did
see the moon. Why? Because it's going
that direction, right? And so if a
person in the west doesn't see it and a
if a person in the far east does not see
it, it doesn't mean that a person in the
far west will not.
However, if a person in the far west
sees it,
right? And excuse me, in the far east
sees it, anyone that follows should be
able to see it at that point, right? And
because of this connectivity, now we
have the ability to, you know, to have
what we now know this phenomenon of the
international sighting. Otherwise, it
was always localized. And there are
instances where Mecca and Medina would
be fasting at different days because one
is further east than the other. And
there are instances where those in North
Africa would be fasting and those in far
east and in North Asia and South
Asia would not be fasting. They would
fast the following day and so forth. And
in that instance, a person goes with
their local. But this all goes back to
what
fasting is when you all fast and
breaking your fast is when you all break
your fast.
This topic we're debating it now. And if
you notice, I didn't mention these
things when before Ramadan because at
that point everybody is
thinks that they have to figure this out
on their own. That's not how it works.
This is a debate and a discussion for
leadership. They may discuss it with
each other. Should we go with
international? Should we go with more
localized sighting? And then once they
agree on something, they all go on that.
But the average Muslim, the average
community member, this is not an
independent topic to research. This is
something that they fast when it is
announced and they break their fast when
it is announced. So easy. If we can't
agree on the moon,
we've got a big problem as Muslim. If we
can't agree on the moon, I mean, there's
only one. Could you imagine if there
were two? What would happen? Right? And
so the point here is that
debating this topic or discussing it, I
went out of my way not to open this
topic until we've already started
fasting. The first day or two is already
worn off. Because if you're speaking to
people at that time, you're speaking to
emotion. And logic and emotion are on
two completely different wavelengths.
One is AM, the other is FM.
Just a reminder of our fundraiser after
JMA. Make sure that you come with your
hands where the deepest pockets that you
have so that we can get the projects
of the masjid and get the masid funding
done this year. And please come
with that intention. Michelle
That's a very nice.